I'm so excited to see you guys to
finally see other faces than my kids
faces I guess I should say namaste to
both of you because this movie is
absolutely incredible
action-packed that I've never seen
before Sam you shot this in a way where
I'm standing right next to Chris so as
your directorial debut what did you
think of the film is that everything you
wanted I think personally you're all I
am a perfectionist that I'm always
looking at bangs and Mainland you know
judging them in retrospect and saying ah
you know I could have done this or could
have done that but that said I'm
extremely proud of what we did I mean
especially the one or being seeing what
when you step back and it's been a while
since I've seen it but when you watch
what Chris and the other people did it
really is mind-blowing I mean it's
something that I haven't really seen
before at least captured in that way a
lot of people have done long takes a lot
of you have done action but just the way
it came across and the performances I
think are unique and I'm really proud of
what we all did that's a great movie and
Chris I mean you're like a rock star I
was watching videos of you in India and
the way the people are all around you on
the streets of India what did you learn
about living in India the culture the
people what what was the appreciation of
the of the country oh it's just
wonderful um it was the first time
shooting there for me and I've never
experienced that kind of enthusiasm and
excitement from the people you know
within the community shooting and I
think it was unique for them to see a
film like this being shot there they
have their own rich wonderful cinema but
their films like this and this style was
very different unique and you know we'd
have you know the moment we left the
hotel 15 talk talks and motorbikes and
stop following us to set we'd have been
thousands of people watching every day
at the end of each take there'd be a big
eruption and applause it's like being in
the Coliseum and you know we we were
nervous about the disruption we were
causing with you know shooting these
chaotic scenes there and I gotta say we
couldn't have done it without their
support and and to have that passion and
excitement just gave us all a boost of
energy and appreciation
you learn any hindi did you learn any
Indian Bollywood songs while you were
there
Eddy any of the culture but there was a
celebration called Diwali that we got -
yeah and so we you know there was we
were immersed as much as we could we
were shooting long days and a lot long
hours but we whenever we could we would
try to you know dip a toe into the local
culture and it was a really wonderful
experience and inspired your daughter's
name I understand because of this
experience rakers know this my wife had
spent time in India many years ago and
and I liked Indiana Jones and so before
this before this experience this is
surreal you're in Australia you're in
United States I'm in Canada this is a
moment for us to adjust to the way life
is now and one of the things is that you
change your ways when you're living at
home so I need to know are you guys
doing chores now are you doing things
out in the house are you teaching your
kids how has it been for you guys yeah I
mean you know yeah you're doing the all
the chores and and and you know that the
teaching the kids would say is I'd I've
almost given up on and I'm just gonna
gonna just just say hey listen kids
you're coming out of this little dumber
than you were you can we have moments
and days where we get but I just feel
like in negotiation is is what takes up
the most time three hours of that and
then maybe 20 minutes of work and
yourself Sam you know staying busy
there's there's never I'm never at a
loss for things to do out here my
property in California and but I've
really enjoyed the the kind of quiet
that has come with this so that usually
it happens after a film is over and you
kind of finish and there's a kind of
reflective period but this has been
unique in that you know it's it's gonna
force us all to stop and consider what
important you know kind of a little self
examination of the lights we were living
and whatnot but I've you know a lot of
it to me is based on attitude and
perspective so I'm just trying to stay
positive and you know stay fit and
healthy physically and mentally and just
be ready for when that man lifts we get
back to making movies you bring up a
really good point what is the one thing
you will never take for granted once
you've had this experience in isolation
mm-hmm Chris
high-fives hugs you know yeah you know
sensing real community in a physical
space you know and look I think it's a
bit of a reminder too of you know we
spent so much time on their phones and
heads in that sort of smartphones and
computers and isolated to a degree in
the past anyway and maybe this is a
snapshot of where we were headed so if
we don't like that we need to get out
there more and and and I think everyone
is under the realization of how much we
create you know the physical interaction
and and being outdoors more and
immersing ourselves in nature more and
not being confined to one space and
isolated so it doesn't make you realize
you appreciate that and you know I got
to see a live concert and me music
festival and are they a thing of a part
of the past in a lot of ways you know is
that that's incredibly you know
unfortunate if that's the case but I
feel like you know we'll get back on top
of it we'll figure it out and we'll be
back out there and hanging out in the
physical realm
until then extraction is a great
distraction it is an amazing movie and I
can't wait for everyone to see it and I
now I want to go to India because I
haven't taken my kids so thank you for
exposing me to a great country like that
thank you guys so much thank you